find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor is the result
of the Cova 19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020 - Oh for this public body is
authorized to meet electronically please
note there is no physical location to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting which was authorized
pursuant to the governor's emergency
order however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming the
following that we are a providing public
access to the meeting by telephone with
additional access possibilities by video
or other electronic means we are
utilizing zoom for this electronic
meeting all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through this
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
clicking on the following website
address HTTP zoom us J nine one one zero
seven one eight eight three two one
we're dialing one of the following phone
numbers one nine - nine - OH
five six oh nine nine or one three oh
one seven one five eight five nine to be
providing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting we
previously gave notice to the public of
the necessary information for accessing
the meeting including how to access the
meeting here saying zoo or
telephonically this information is
printed in your house calendar C
providing a mechanism for the public to
alert the public body during the meeting
if there are problems with access if
anyone has a problem please call six
zero three two seven one three six zero
zero or email H as in house
C as in committee s s and services ad le
G
State NH u-s-d-a journey of the meeting
if the public is unable to access the
meeting in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled I want
to introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us Gen 4 House
Committee researcher is the meeting host
additional House committee services
staff providing support our Brad green
doin am smiling and Cristina Dyer this
is a work session on HB 1563 FN & HP
1627 FN we will take them in that order
the Ways and Means Committee held a
public hearing on HB 1563 FN March the
4th and a public hearing on HB 1627 FN
March the 5th the purpose of a work
session is for the committee itself to
discuss the bill and register opinions
before we move to a vote at another time
the chairman retains the ability to call
on certain individuals who have
indicated that they have new information
since the public hearing and not to call
on other attendees who may also wish to
speak because the main purpose of this
meeting is for the members to discuss
among themselves copies of the bills and
other relevant materials have been
posted on the main page of the General
Court website under the heading remote
meetings please note that if any votes
are taken during this meeting they shall
be done by roll call vote however there
should be no dispositive votes in a work
session let us start the meeting by
taking roll call attendance when each
member states their presence
please also state whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
I believe the clerk should hold the roll
okay second rep Sarah Malloy would you
representative all me a present
on at home in Lebanon alone
representative Eames dunked it in
Jeffrey and my dog is with me
representative Southworth at home in
Dover alone clerk Molloy is at home and
no one else is in the room here oh yeah
I think yeah I'm always representing
champey I just interrupt for a minute
does it use its talking occasionally I
muted him I don't think he realized that
he was unmuted for role okay thank you
understand Malloy may continue
represented Schamberg I see a box there
we go representative Schamberg here in
wilmut and alone presentative tucker
here along in Randolph representing
bunker and present I'm in Exeter and I'm
in a private room representative Marlowe
representative Griffith
president and alone
representative locked in there I'll say
representative Stringham I'm here in
Lincoln by myself
representative major air and plasto by
myself
representative Griffin I'm here in
Windham by myself
XANA Valerie you're very hard to hear if
you could do something about it your
your volume that would help you don't
have to reply or ever said Malloy
my mic was minute I'm here alone Thank
You representative burns I'll repeat
representative to set I see a box here
then yes I've seen him do said we can't
representative to say I'm not hearing an
acknowledgment I've said just said do
what sounds like he's talking to someone
else oh oh dear I have not heard of here
and I'm buying who's with me so I want
to be active would it be completely
accurate about this for now I'll mark
not here we'll move on representative
Edwards you won't be here okay
sedative Burstein good morning I'm here
in beautiful Nottingham New Hampshire
[Music]
there are sixteen present and four not
present did I not call Oh representative
but that's the committee is somebody
sitting in for someone if spine is a
replacement for burns oh I'm sorry
okay so representative Lang I'm you
thank you I couldn't undo my self
representative Lang I'm in my home
office in San Burton New Hampshire and I
am alone thank you thank you so that
takes us to 17 present three absent I
still see representative sets name on
the screen that I have not heard all
representative Griffith Griffith and
representative Burstein would like to be
recognized we're just gonna wait for
represent Melanie to come back on
Webster Anna Burstein and then and
represent Griffith also and okay we'll
start with representative bursting thank
you yep Fred just texted me free
representative to set just texted me
saying he's having computer problems
right now but he managed to introduce
himself I hope while I was off to
stopping the phone which unfortunately
is completely unstoppable I'm sorry to
interrupt represent me but represent
Burstein if you have an audience with
representative Doucette and he's able to
resolve his issues if he could maybe
raise his hand when he gets back I just
don't want to leave him unmuted while
he's sorting that out
okay be computer issues that on bread
greenland can help with I have no idea
tell him to reach out to Brad you can't
solve it yeah and if he wants us to
reach out to him just oh he just he just
sex me saying just tell them to unmute
me I think I have the audio fixed okay
okay oh is that working yes my apologies
it's all on my end with my internet
connection please forgive me we all have
problems like that
so are you present and alone yes ma'am
thank you
attendance is now 18 yes to not
answering or an IV attendance thank you
so we are going to take amendment House
bill 50 in 63 first on I wanted to make
a short statement before we start which
is that I seem to have been derelict at
the beginning of this term in getting
people to understand that our committee
under the rules has a responsibility to
on on make sure that dedicated funds
that are being changed or dedicated
funds that are new on are working
appropriately are sourced appropriately
on are raising the right kind of money
for the job and vice versa on and on
this is why we spend a fair amount of
time on some things that you may think
are the policy of prior committee this
both of these bills actually fall into
this category
so represent bursting has a question or
a comment or both
and I won't want him to talk um could
you unmute madam chair this is a second
committee bill and I would just like you
to refresh our memory on what that means
to be a second committee bill and does
that mean there are any boundaries on
this discussion or is the breadth of the
discussion limited to the dedicated fund
or we will or will we be revisiting
policy aspects of this bill that were
discussed by the prior committee
judiciary on their February 5th exact
session well if we are going to discuss
the amendment which I thought was most
of the reason for this work session on
the work session is changing the policy
of the first committee so I think to
that extent we are going to have in the
sense that in our sense of a dedicated
fund which has to be be tailored to the
objective of the fund the objective has
to be clear and the the both the
sourcing and the amount of money has to
be appropriate to to that fund and in
removing this from governor and council
which in the public hearing this
committee discussed was on not
appropriate within the administrative
structure of the state and putting it
adjusting the subsection before the one
that was dealt with in the first
committee to mirror the section that was
dealt with in that on we have
I have a new amendment which does deal
with the policy of the first committee
and and change it somewhat from what it
had been before particularly in the
aspects of what a dedicated fund does
and how it operates so on it is a little
difficult to figure out the boundaries
on this one and an appropriate response
could be simply to take the bill and
either interim study or ITL it so that
it can go back to the to the sponsor and
be submitted as as a clean bill -
whichever committee is considered
appropriate next term because we may
have different people deciding which
bills go where okay so it sounds to me
like you're going to allow a lot a lot
of latitude and well you don't know the
boundaries I think on one of the
objectives of the bill was to remove the
control from the AG's office - anywhere
else and that was fairly clear in the
original on in the public hearing I
would hope that we would not have a
discussion of what we learned in the
public hearing on particularly if five
people are going to to do the same
discussion we do have the additional
problem that on the people who would
have been opposed to the bill did not
notice the bill going through the first
committee and are ready to appear right
now which is to try
late but this whole procedure is a
trifle late because not just a Kovac but
of the the lack of complete presentation
either in our public hearing or in the
public hearing apparently of the first
committee I understand it was only
represented by the AG's person who is
here in the audience I believe so you're
gonna allow testimony even though this
is a work session because the certain
parties were unaware of the first time
the bill was heard but can you extend
that courtesy to all parties oh yes on
the trouble is we you have a great
number of people in the audience that
would wish to talk I hope that they will
if they hear someone else saying
something that they will not feel that
they have to repeat it and I hope the
same would be true of the four people
that three or four people that seem to
be on the other side I'm not sure where
they all are right I have no idea if
they want to speak or not they're just
here to make themselves available to the
committee should they be it's alright as
far as I know but perhaps some of them
want to speak yeah well it is difficult
in this format because on unless someone
inside the committee knows what they'd
have to offer on it we can't find out
until they've talked it goes
but I'm confident you will Shepherd us
to the promised land
I will try so I think the the amendment
came from represent Burstein and
representative Spillane representative
bursting is the one on the committee so
I think he ought to explain the
amendment I hope everybody has read it
they half the committee didn't get it
till recently thank you madam chair as
we all know this is a second committee
bill the bill was originally in
Judiciary Committee and then it came to
the floor of the house on February 19th
and passed 329 221 the motion was ought
to pass so it seems from that first vote
that there's a tremendous appetite from
the house for the spirit of this bill
and when ways and means again it's work
on the bill my notes showed that the
chair had some significant problems with
the bill regarding the technical
application of the bill not the spirit
of the bill but the implementation of it
so this amendment tried to address all
of that and I believe it did I just as
concise as I can be this money redirects
funds from the drug forfeiture fund to
you go towards treatment instead of
enforcement the sponsor of the bill and
I were very careful to be as fair as we
can and depending on the situation it's
possible law enforcement could actually
receive bigger reimbursements than they
were receiving before but once they
reimburse for everything all
out-of-pocket expenses related to the
prosecution after that the money would
go towards drug treatment to be
administered by the Department of HHS
thank you we did not in our public
hearing discussed the the removal from
the purposes of the dedicated fund of on
a number of the mechanisms for drug
enforcement on that that are in the bill
and we did not do it because there was
nobody present who could talk to us
about that on except on the gentleman
from the Department of Justice who did
not have at that time sheets that I
think we got afterwards about where
exactly the money was being spent at
different times and how much money which
is under $500,000 a year was going into
it and mr. Locke the attorney Locke from
the AG's office did provide this I
believe it was after the commentary it's
been quite a while now so perhaps we
should start by having him talk about
where the money has been been going and
how much of it we know that 10% of it
went to Health and Human Services but we
don't know where the rest of it was
going except through this represent me
I'm sorry to interrupt you let you know
that representative of Romney said his
hand up don't look to recognize him
first or the attorney I think we should
rip his phone recognizer up scent of a
bra me first because
and he's been talking with where the
attorney general's office I believe
Sanford Bharani okay yep thank you rob
you get you're absolutely correct that
the bill that came to us was flawed not
necessarily always means kind of way but
it was going to direct the funds to the
governor and we heard from attorney
Fenella the governor's a prime attorney
that that they don't have they don't
have this question to spend that money
it has to go to an agency so then then
and that was in my last meeting then we
received this amendment and when I look
at the amendment and I do want others to
look at this when you go to the bottom
two the number two when the amendment
modifies women and it that's where it
gives the authority for the dispense for
the phone to the DHHS and takes it away
from the Attorney General the only
problem is that when you look at the
current statute when you look at Roman
two and three it still says that the
AG's office is is responsible for
reporting back to the governor and
Executive Council and that the attorney
general's office shall adopt rules so
the amendment as is is flawed
from my perspective so so just goes on
to address that
I think the amenities work adopt this
and we could talk about policy later on
but those are just some perturbations I
made and anybody else wants to react to
that or so the same thing that I saw
should raise your hand I guess for now
thank you mister I clarify we're talking
about
RSA 318 b-17 B which I had sent to the
entire committee and sections Roman 1
and reports that's the top port the
bottom the sex decision
change was to amend RSA 318 being : 17
Dead Sea and we read that the SD gives
the DNA chaste responsibility for that
fund takes it away from the Attorney
General which okay but it's it's silent
when it comes to woman two and three and
they in the current statute where the AG
is still responsible for reporting and
adopting rules right the whole
forfeiture process right so I you know
the options we have is just to do what
you earlier said is to either I kill
this bill or study it or devote at least
as bill just amendments gonna have to be
fixed again and I guess at the end of
our discussion here whether it's worth
trying to fix this amendment or not
everything that al me represent aims
would like to be recognized I'm
representative Eames yeah thank you
I just I want to second what
representative Romney has just pointed
out that there's still technical
problems with the bill
as it would be amended by the proposed
amendment that he has pointed out there
there's certainly an issue there and I
also find myself puzzling over the fact
that the proposed amendment has two
agencies taking money out of the drug
forfeiture fund with I think an unclear
line between the two if you look at the
new paragraph that's being introduced at
seventeen B a row and five the from the
funds available in the drug forfeiture
fund the Department of Justice job pay
and the first subparagraph is basically
the expenses of the proceeding that
generates the fund so that's that's a in
effect that's saying that the the net
after expenses will be in the drug will
still be in the drug forfeiture fund
that makes sense
but the second item is is I think
open-ended it's reimburse all direct
costs incurred in the arrest and
prosecution of a person that would be
any person for a criminal violation of
this chapter on a case-by-case basis so
there's an ongoing potential expense for
draw down by the Department of Justice
and well that activity is going on in
the Department of Justice on the other
side with now the Department of Health
and Human Services enabled to draw this
phone any balance remaining in the drug
forfeiture fund is administered by the
private Health and Human Services well
what is that balance it's a dynamic
situation and with one agency and the
other agency both involved it seems to
me it's a recipe for trouble that's this
one those are my comments thank you
thank you on representative Southworth
has his hand up thank you
I want to echo the other concerns and in
terms of the discussion of the hearing
it seems like we're really shifting not
from the merits of the bill or you know
the good intentions so on things that
were voted before we really need to
decide is it ready for primetime is it
something that really be ready for a
June boat and I almost think we don't
have all the information we need to
decide that except that the more we talk
the more complicated it gets to improve
the amendment thank you on I'd like to
point out also that the fund is supposed
to be administered in Health and Human
Services but on only the balance
remaining in the fund after DOJ has done
the expenditures allowed in the new
section one on are supposed to go to
Health and Human Services I don't I
think does the does the committee want
to hear from the woman from Health and
Human Services that is present in the
audience that has been following this
bill apparently it being raised in the
answer thumbs up or thumbs down yes
thumbs up or thumbs down I don't think
we've got thumbs here but raising your
hand we have at least we have two people
requesting that 3/4 there more of them
okay so I and I think that I didn't
beforehand that I didn't manage to get
my lists printed out as the people that
were in the audience
on Jen do you have the woman from the
heo Higgins her name it represent so
Higgins miss Oh Higgins if you could
raise your hand you'll pop up to the top
of the list for us it's just a long list
it is a very long list we saw earlier I
think this is the first time any of us
are having to deal with this kind of
complication in I don't see her now
unless she's one of the phone numbers I
think we saw her earlier and she's not
there now okay so um representative Lang
has his hand physically up yes yes
represent of Lang if you could and
representative Romney has his hand up he
would know probably what's going on
we'll ask her first and represent Lang
if you can use the raise hand on
function in the panelists participants
on your I would have loved to do that
except that's not working for me I can't
raise my hand that's why I was doing
this okay
raise your hand is at the very bottom of
the panelists list unless you are on a
Mac in which case it is under other down
there somehow
if you click participants I found it
ok great so I think that we will we will
ask rip senator from me first
Wow Jennifer o'higgins has reappeared oh
good raised her hand would you like to
okay miss O'Hagan's you're on hi there
this is Jennifer Oh Higgins I'm the
senior policy analyst for behavioral
health and legislative liaison I was had
called in since I don't have great
internet connection so then when you
called on me I had to relog into zoom so
I'm sorry about that confusion so we
received the amendment yesterday so we
haven't really had time to do a whole
fiscal review at this point but I think
that we have a little bit of confusion
between you know section 1 and section 2
of the bill where it with the Department
of Justice currently administering the
fund and the second piece of the bill
having you know the fund be administered
by DHHS I think there's there's
currently that 10-percent set-aside for
DHHS and I don't know that we have the
expertise in the department to be able
to reimburse for costs incurred by
arrests and prosecutions I think that
that expertise does the live with the
DOJ so I would you know send it off to
them for that question as far as
administering and any funding around
prevention treatment and recovery that
is where you know our expertise would
would come into play and if you have any
questions for me I'm happy to try to
field them as best I can
thank you is there anyone who has
questions mr. Higgins representives
Lange thank you so I I'm reading this
the way I I'm reading it is that after a
forfeiture first the Department of
Justice pays its expenses under one in
two of subsection 5 they're responsible
the Department of Justice is responsible
for allocating those funds and then
anything that's left over at the end of
the fiscal year except for 10% so 90% of
whatever balance is left over is then
shifted to Health and Human Services for
treatment is that who I'm reading this
and I don't believe mr. Higgins can
answer that since they seem to have just
seen the amendment yesterday but the
balance yes the balance seems to shift
over that at that point but all of this
money is going into the drug forfeiture
fund and is going in from work by the
DOJ on before that shifts of the 10%
happens yet in section 2 it says that
the fund is going to in the Treasury is
going to be administered entire entirely
by the Department of Health and Human
Services so presumably the DOJ would
have to report back for what seems to be
the majority of the money to the
Department of Health and Human Services
in order to get permission to spend it
and that seems a little unworkable to me
anyway Eames eager to contribute did you
put your handbag down you say okay I
think you're James has his hand up
apparently headed up earlier no I just
wanted to respond to representative
Lange's points and just I think if you
look closely a new language
subparagraphs one and two that the take
out from the fund is broader than what
you think it might be or what you
suggested it might be on first blush the
there's two paragraphs it's one is very
clear it's a reasonable cost of the the
forfeiture proceeding to is broader than
the forfeiture proceeding it's all
direct costs in the arrest and
prosecution of a person on a
case-by-case basis
so it's anticipating many cases
case-by-case reimbursement of costs
that's ongoing it's beyond the
forfeiture proceeding if it said in
their reimburse all direct costs
incurred in the arrest and prosecution
of a person involved in the matter
referenced in subparagraph one it would
be contained by that particular case
where the money with there was
generating them the money that's going
to the drug drug forfeiture fund but
it's not it's much broader that's my
point and that's a problem thank you on
Brooks and berstein has his hand up yeah
thank you
it's currently we're reimbursing for
this it isn't and that's what we're
doing right now representative Eames but
wouldn't a dynamic aspect of ongoing I
mean the money is not dispersed until
after everything is finished that's how
it's currently working this doesn't
change that so um while your point about
it being ongoing costs and the dinah
sysm regarding that that's going on
right now and they get and those
reimbursements made to law enforcement
for all out-of-pocket expenses this
doesn't vary respond yes yeah the
problem in my trying to respond to that
gets to I think the problem that we're
encountering
we don't have anybody
maybe this proceeding isn't well set up
to give us the full picture of how this
fund operates has operated is intended
to operate in the future we're digging
into a policy in an activity area that
we're not expert in and I don't know
exactly how its operated in the past my
sense is that that these phrases they
weren't in subparagraphs before have
enabled the Department of Justice to
reimburse for proceedings that reach
beyond particular proceedings that
actually generate the funds but I don't
know that for a fact
so one of the difficulties that I have
and why I leaned towards towards sending
this bill back for reworking so that it
can be properly reviewed by a first
committee is that that we're operating
on thin ice we don't really understand
the full dimensions of this thing and we
can't thank you rips in and aims on
representing Brahmi
is next and then represented streams his
point perhaps Shawn could add some some
information as to how the phone actually
works today I'd like to make sure we
hear from the chief Foskey from Bedford
who understands the police changed whom
they've been they've been studying this
for a couple of weeks so now so I think
they have some things they want to say
as well thank you thank you do I
understand they received the amendment
several weeks ago so I provided it to
them
what IQ and focuses our site didn't see
whenever you sent it out it got
forwarded on I didn't send it out until
extremely recently because I didn't
receive it until extremely recently on
read perhaps on
I cannot remember his his name the
charlatan the police chief briefed on
skeet some ski thank you it is he
willing to speak for a minute is he on
this list yeah just a minute I wish
these lists were alphabetical its
alphabetical by first name which makes
it a little challenging he's raised his
hand for us thank you thank you so we
would like to he's he's on now an
episode the Sun ski I think yes good
morning can you hear me yes okay great
madam chair and members of the committee
for giving the Chiefs of Police a few
moments to discuss this and I'll go
directly to the core of your discussion
which I think I may be able to help you
with and and if I may in my own farm
background vernacular this is a chicken
in the egg sort of discussion here with
respect to the source of these funds the
way that this bill is amended and likely
to be administered by DHHS a non-law
enforcement agency will eventually
result in the fund going to zero over
time and the reason why this assumption
is being made by the Chiefs is that the
funds in
the drug asset forfeiture fund go
directly to support the investigations
that result in the seizures from drug
traffickers that replenish the fund and
over time when you siphon off funds for
a non-law enforcement investigative
purpose eventually there will be less
funds available to conduct
investigations and they're at they're
for the source of the funds will
eventually dry up so as amended we
believe that over time that this
administration readmit astray ssin of
what was originally intended to support
drug trafficking investigations and
shift the burden from the taxpayer to
the drug trafficker will eventually
result in the shifting back to the
taxpayer and that's why we are opposed
to it simply because it will eventually
result in the dilution and the
elimination of the funds available to
conduct investigations and therefore no
representative Stringham had his hand
out still we had heard some testimony
about how the existing funds are managed
I guess of the AG's office and most of
my what I saw was you know wasn't very
sophisticated accounting so the there
was significant portion of money that
was kind of building up because it was
being held probably I believe you know
because it couldn't be released since
your final dispensation and the case
might not have been heard yet so there
was kind of more funds there then then
were active and and that's at such time
they felt that the disposition of a case
was final that's when the funds were
being apportioned
and back to police for those who brought
in the funds are presumably for
additional investigative purposes or the
other uses that were in there so I just
thought I would bring that bring that
back in and follow up to representative
Eames and our representative first in
his comments thank you represent
estrellas
would that imply that who would think
that a performance audit would be in
order for this program ever since - no I
would think so so are their
representatives bursting did you have
your hand up again or had it not gone
down it's up thank you I think I want to
just sort of power onto what
representative Stringham was saying and
I believe that one of the motivations
for the original bill was the lack of
transparency as a matter of fact if
justice gives New Hampshire a d-minus
ranking for forfeiture transparency and
accountability and I believe
representative Spillane the prime
sponsor of this bill would like to speak
more to that so I requested he'd be
permitted to speak okay could we bring
I'm blanking on his first name so that
we can find it unless he'll raise his
hand he's ready to go okay good
Thank You members of the committee am I
able to be heard right
yes okay I want to thank you all for
giving me the opportunity to speak we
have worked hard on this bill and I
think as you could see with the previous
vote on the House floor that it is
something that the goal is is achievable
and something that a great many of the
representatives want to see happen part
of that is transparency because as we've
seen there is ZERO accountability for
any amount of the monies except for the
10% that goes to thhs right now the rest
of the money goes into a black hole
where we are told that you know just
trust us it's being used for further
arrests I want to also point out that
the the insinuation that arrests and
prosecution of drug trafficking will
cease if they don't have this money is
fallacious and the the mere insinuation
that we would stop arresting people is
really a ridiculous one in my opinion
there is not going to be a halt to law
enforcement prosecution and arrest of
drug traffickers in the state it will
not happen we will continue to arrest
but we have a terrible problem with our
opioid crisis we've lost 68 more people
to the opioid crisis so far this year
that's just this year in 2020 and we're
going to continue seeing these numbers
especially with this opioid crisis
converging with the the Kovich shutdown
we saw it during the Kovich shutdown
that treatment programs were being
stopped that people were not they people
who were working and trying to become
sober
lost their jobs which pushed them back
into isolation and desperation and turn
them back to drugs this money can go
very far inmate
sure that we can continue providing
services and it makes the person who
victimized these people pay for their
recovery it is taking the ill-gotten
gains from the drug trafficking and
using it to restore people and to give
them hope and to change their lives
so I would hope that if there are any
minor details that we need to iron out
continue still going on with this this
amendment I mean we tried our best to
address every issue that was brought up
in the last public hearing that that you
guys found but we are willing to
continue working on this and clean it up
in any way that you think is necessary
to make sure that it passes muster
because the goal is achievable and it's
an it's a worthwhile goal to be able to
provide this money to those who need
help recovering from the drug
traffickers okay thank you I would like
to go to both mr. Locke Attorney lock on
and to mr. Higgins again to ask how much
money they think we are talking about
relative to the amount of money that is
going to that goal already elsewhere on
but do we just moved his hand
representative about me do you want to
say something first oh you just if you
don't mind so if more money is going to
treatment then where is the money coming
from to the
it sounds like the only other place if
it's a zero-sum game play said that it
comes from the taxpayers
whether it be property taxpayers or a
state you know taxpayers can fund the
enforcement port and that's where I'm
that's where I get confused because just
saying you're doing this because you
want more money to go into Jordan
treatment but that's fine but what about
where does the money come from
eventually we're gonna be paying that
taxpayers it sounds like they're going
to be paying or for something here it
was that correct we we already pay for
drug enforcement this small amount when
it comes to the overall size of the
police budget is almost nothing to them
we are not going to stop the law
enforcement just because this money is
redirected this this is a twofold bill
it increases the transparency because it
now gives a dedicated fund to that money
that is drug forfeiture money from the
criminals and puts it under the spending
for those programs where it's
accountable and we can see where it's
going which will increase the
transparency of this entire drug
forfeiture process and on top of it the
law enforcement budget is is not even
going to decrease by a hundredth of a
percent because of this it's ridiculous
to think that that this small amount is
making a dent at all in what we've
already paid funding for law enforcement
law enforcement activities are going to
continue to go on we have federal grant
money that we use continually for drug
enforcement that the federal authorities
are involved in it and when they get
involved with the drug forfeiture they
get their bite of our money as well
before they take before we get to take
our portion so this is not a situation
that's going to shift taxpayer money
suddenly to increase the police budget
the police already have their budget and
they are already
using that money to arrest people and
convict them and that's not going to
stop but these facilities need it we
just lost last year our only youth
residential facility in New Hampshire
for treatment it shut down and we don't
have another one right now
and mrs. Johnston who lost her son last
Thanksgiving is is on the phone
listening as well and she had to send
her son to California for residential
treatment do we want to be the state
that has to export our children with
drug abuse problems so that they can
have treatment or do we want to be able
to take care of our children and make
them whole again Thank You
representative Spillane I have
representatives hands I want to
interrupt this and introduce some facts
to this I would like to listen to MS
O'Higgins talk about how much money I
hope she has this it doesn't have to be
precise how much money is being spent on
the opioid crisis right now by the state
and then on on attorney Rock talk about
how much money would be left after the
reasonable expenses of forfeiture
proceedings and reimbursement of all
direct costs in the rest and protection
so could we call again on news O'Hagan's
would she be willing to come up Jenny oh
yeah she's label - hi there I would have
to get back to you on which portions are
state license verses our grants and
pieces like that so I wouldn't be able
here what part of it is grants and what
part of it is is state money the
question is how much is the state
spending right now I'm not sure I'd have
to get back to you okay you don't have
any idea whether it's millions tens of
millions or 250 thousand dollars I'm
sorry then muted and unmuted back and
forth we I mean we have several large
grants including a block a block grant
as well as the state opioid response
grant currently that you know is fifty
five million dollars so nope it's not
two hundred fifty thousand but you know
again we I would have to just like break
out those investments based on what your
what information you're looking for
thank you but it's it's in the tens of
millions thank you yes okay
attorney Locke could could you get on
and talk to us about roughly how much
money is left over after you pay for the
items that are in section one the
reasonable expenses of forfeiture
proceedings and the reimbursement of
sure I'm happy to kind of talk a little
bit about that unfortunately I can't
give you concrete because of obviously
from year to year based on the number of
forfeitures we do but the the value of
the different forfeit but also it's
going to depend a little bit on how this
gets construed if it gets construed as
you get reimbursed kind of as the
forfeiture is done so for example if we
forfeiture of $2,000 and that money can
only be used to reimburse the
investigation that led seizure of that
$2,000 that is going to probably see a
far less false far amount of money make
its way to digest
then if the forfeiture were whether we
could take all the forfeitures and
aggregate and reimburse costs the issues
here of some of the and some of the
other issues that tie into this in terms
of reimbursement and relying upon
reimbursement is the fact that from
seizure of the funds to confine all
disposition of the forfeiture proceeding
that can take months if not years the
complete and that is a required aspect
before a forfeiture can be completed and
the doctor receives those funds is that
there has to be a conviction and then
the forfeiture proceeding was all and so
there isn't you know there isn't kind of
this that there's going to need to be
essentially if before that reimbursement
can occur that money is being put
forward by taxes at that point I mean if
there's no other funds abroad and I
really hope you can hear me because if
you almost stop moving oh we can hear
you yes you can still talk could you
could you just give a rough estimate of
what proportion of the $500,000 is
actually under $500,000 but I comes in
to this drug forfeiture fund that would
be available to go out after the
forfeiture and direct costs I I don't
know if I could give you a good estimate
of that honestly I worked I spoke with
our director of administration of that
would look like and it just it's such a
fundamental change to the model we'd
have to account for kind of all the
hours that are putting into just doing
forfeitures on our end let alone the ten
County Attorneys offices hunt police
departments that do this work across the
Dave we don't those numbers we just
don't have access to to make that
determination on their end would you say
that that at most half of the money
available in that fund would be able to
to go on to to determination by the
Department of Health and Human Services
did you say that most half I would be on
the generous end I think after the
reimbursements there would not be a
substantial amount of money left to go
thank you so now I think we can go back
there are four hands under panelists the
first students were upset over he he's
had his hand up the number for quite a
while very faint if you could speak up
representative O'Leary okay I put this
brand new talk with my chief he needs
the money from this and route 111
through Hudson it's a corridor they did
a study on stops and there's a guy here
in town even when as far as suing the
police department only to find out that
the number of people stopped to a quote
both Hispanic were actually carrying
drugs because they had masked plates
they were coming up from Lawrence the
issue is not whether or not we need drug
enforcement money as Jim representative
explained had said the issue is
what accounting takes place I don't want
to attack the attorney general's office
but attorney Locke just said we just
don't have the numbers or the question
is who is keeping track of the numbers
what is happening where is the money
going
not to individual CEO and our CEOs but
informing witnesses or or for behind
this apartment at this location for a
drug Buy I don't care about that I just
want the general categories out where
they can be seen in public and people
know that this money isn't a slush fund
for the AG and for the police
departments they need the money but as
the vote house showed no one knows where
this money is it's a big black hole and
in other states have reflected
negatively upon the good work in New
Hampshire because of their behavior so
we need to get this right and I would
strongly recommend that we retain this
and get it right so that we can push it
Romy what's next a fund in excess of a
million dollars to the general fund that
goes away with this because it's under
the same section as as section 17 C so
that's one one thought the other one is
what I'd like to hear from I guess
there's two issues outstanding there's
concern about transparency
that the what does what does the AG's
office Shimano Hurlock do in terms of
reporting annually to the governor and
the Executive Council I mean what is
present to them in number one and number
two for representative on the prime
sponsor and and for was in Aberdeen
there's a contradiction in what's being
said because rigs are postings that
actually the police enforcement officers
would get more funds from this amendment
and but the prime sponsor is arguing
that they're getting too much and that
we need more to go to the to the
treatment so I'm not quite sure what it
is which way I need I need represents
blame to try to react to that and
perhaps Shawn law can react to my first
comment well I mean would you like me to
recognize representative Lane first okay
we cannot spend the whole two hours on
this thank you madam chair thank you yes
with a question representative of Romney
I think that the way I heard
representative Burstein comment he was
saying it is possible that a police
department could get more under the new
way of doing this and that is because we
are actually taking into account their
actual reimbursement for their costs
that they've expended rather than just
giving them a lump sum or a disbursement
in general so yes there's there's
because we also take that out first
there's a chance that not that DHHS
doesn't get much but on those large drug
busts and those large confiscations once
the conviction is made and
we reimburse all the expenses incurred
through the arrests in the trial
DHHS will get some money and no it's not
a dependable amount but every bit that
we can give to some of these treatment
facilities helps thank you I want to
recognize rips and in flying and then
represent Burstein and then represented
southwards and then I want to call on
Chris Shea with a question thank you
madam chairman
so I guess my question is I'm a little
confused by the conversation that it
will cost taxpayers money because in the
amendment at least it reimburses all the
cost of an investigation back to the law
enforcement agency for the seizure so I
don't see a taxpayer paying a fee here
that they're not already paying so
they're getting the same reimbursement I
think the issue at hand is that under
the current law 45% of the funds are
returned to the arresting agency
responsible for the seizure and yet
there's no direct correlation that 45%
was relative to their cost that could
have cost them more than 45% of the
seizure could have cost some less than
45% of the season I think what this bill
an amendment is trying to do is to not
make this worse is to make sure that
agencies get the appropriate amount of
money if it's more than 45% they'll get
more than 45% if it's less than 45% then
no recoup their costs and not create a
fund to to start doing other
investigations that may or may not be
appropriate so I think it's really for
the eight for the prosecutions that are
necessary that result in forfeiture and
and then sending the rest of the money
over to treatment where it belongs so I
guess I'm unless I'm reading that wrong
I don't see an expense going backs to
the taxpayer for these events that in
fact the agencies are being reimbursed
for the actual cost and not just an
arbitrary 45% number that isn't relative
to their costs at all now yes I wanna
thank you I think it's in the eye of
whoever is doing the accounting of this
but represented Burstein thank you let
me address what representative of Romney
said about we struck the million dollars
out of that any money in excess that
would go to the general fund
I'm just looking at the past four years
how much money came in and we've never
even approached a million dollars I
think that the most we did was in fiscal
2018 where we took in a little more than
half a million dollars other than that
the years I'm looking at around two
hundred thousand for two years and three
hundred and sixty seven thousand for one
of the other years of that money
DHHS got 36 for 2019 DHHS got thirty six
thousand DOJ got one hundred and sixty
nine thousand and a local police and
state police got one hundred and sixty
one thousand but we're not trying to cut
anybody's budget here
and I would suggest that introduction
should not be funded this this way they
go through a budget process like every
other agency we're just trying to steer
more money towards DHHS in some cases
and and as we crafted this amendment
representative Spillane and I were well
aware of this there can be some cases
where law enforcement will get a bigger
reimbursement than they got before they
should get if they have out-of-pocket
expenses by all means they should be
reimbursed for those the bill and I
believe everyone on this call voted yes
the first time around that doesn't bind
you the second time around but I'm under
the impression that there's an appetite
for this to get more funding towards
treatment if that's if your opinion is
changed on that I'd love to know that
but I'm operating under the premise that
100% of the Ways and Means Committee
supported this the first time and that's
why I'm working so hard to try and
thank you
I don't believe very many of us had read
the bill originally so on the first
committee vote is yes always something
that we have to take a look at when we
do see the bill but on South Worth was
next and then I do want to ask Chris Jay
to talk to us as well thank you thank
you madam chair am I on now yes
again thank you I want to echo the
comments of my usual seatmate
representative you Larry I'm just
wondering at what point it would be in
order to do a straw vote for those who
are interested in retraining this bill
have difficulty in figuring out it just
occurred to me last night that we might
want to do straw votes I don't think
we're allowed to do straw votes are we
Jim I don't know that you're not allowed
per se especially since it's not an
official vote by any means and you're
making clear that it's a straw vote
I'm not sure the best way that you would
want to approach that since you
generally just do a raising of hands you
could probably tried to do that
virtually if you want to do and we can't
see everybody function yeah okay before
we do Oh representative will ascend
stand up earlier and it's back
representative will Griffith excuse me
well it's okay I'm curious if we can use
the poll function through zoom to do
something like that I don't think that
we have that available in this yeah okay
and we need to I I want us to listen to
Christopher Chris Shea from El Bao and
he is not from the audit division I
can't remember whether he has ever been
on the audience division but whether he
thinks that a performance audit of the
accounting by DOJ for this program is
something that could be done and he may
not want to apply on whether it would be
useful or not
I represent mommy I heard the question
and yes I did work on the audit division
for on the performance ten years you
could do a performance audit as part of
a performance audit they would look at
the finances but what they would be
probably focused on and I say probably
because performance audits go through
the joint committee so they would give
the charge to the performance audit over
the performance audit oversight
committee would give the charge to our
owners as to what they would like
addressed if you're looking at
efficiencies or effectiveness of how the
monies being spent or if it's being
spent in the place was that the
legislature thought it was going based
on the way the statutes are written and
that's certainly something a performance
thought it could look at if you're more
interested in accounting for did money
go to the right agencies in the right
amounts that might be a financial audit
but a performance thought it could look
at that as well and a performance audit
could look and on whether the accounting
was broken down in sufficient detail to
be able to figure out whether it was
doing what the legislature wanted that's
correct
yeah the performance audits was they
would do that as part of a performance
audit they would look at the money
that's been appropriated to a program
that's being audited and is it being
spent the correct way it's just not a
financial audit it's just more of a you
a but the audit has the ability to bring
financial auditors in if nests excuse me
if necessary if they wanted
more of a financial audit that they
could you know include as part of an
performance audit but I think it
depending on the scope of the question
definitely a performance audit could be
done and it might be useful in terms of
just understanding whether this
particular fund is paying for the
programs that it was intended to pay for
and achieving the results that were
expected and then just making sure the
money goes to the right buckets
hopefully that helps with the question
thank you and the last question for that
is on hence the Department of Justice
had a performance audit ever is this
allowed vomits ought to be done of the
Department of Justice yes oh yeah yep so
I mean the depending on the type of
audit I mean that the type of them from
can we look at you know would be kept
confidential right so we wouldn't be
painting an audit you never see names
and an audit we try to generalize you
know that the agency that was
responsible for a particular function
that they do the job they were asked to
do and what results did you see from
that so there so that would be kind of a
general focus of a performance on it but
yeah we in terms of this where it's a
fund he would be basically looking at
probably several different agencies that
get the money from the fund right cuz
Health and Human Services gets a piece
of this you'd be looking at you know is
the accounting done by the Attorney
General correct in terms of how much
percent goes to each bucket and then
following each of the buckets to see
that that money spent the way that it
was intended but yes the our office
could do an audit of the Attorney
General's Office thank you and it
probably wouldn't be able to start until
late in the year or next year right so
again with performance audits
there's the legislative performance
audit an oversight committee that
directs the the topics that they like
audited and a list of topics that have
kind of in play at the moment so our
auditors are two audits were just ending
so they would be starting to hot
performance and one was started when we
exited the building back in March it
would probably not happen until later
here or early next year that they would
get a chance to start that okay thank
you very much I think that helps to
clarify that particular option I believe
that on we have several options here on
the option we do not have is to do on
substantial further amendment of this
this amendment unless we unless it is
done within the next couple of days and
available to the whole committee on next
week at which time there would probably
be a fair amount of discussion of it and
I guess at that point we would be able
to free to do the discussion again in
the exact session which exact session is
going to have to be short whenever it is
because we don't have a we don't get
much more bandwidth out of the general
court for this or whether that point
most motions of the other kinds which
would be either interim study or ITL to
allow the sponsors to develop it again
on if we did in ITL
on I believe with interim study we don't
get to write anything or do we gen I
can't remember now the interim study
motion will go to the full chamber and
bill you would keep with ya
so the interns no we can't do enter on a
retained bill the first term here is for
sure a B and there is a committee report
yeah so there is a committee reports
either of those could include a request
for a performance audit if we wanted to
go that route so I don't know if there's
any further option in this I'm not
seeing any hands go up so let us try
this you can vote for as many of these
as you want by raising your hand this is
a straw vote
it is totally non-binding on just as the
first committee vote is not not not
binding on the second committee when it
gets its own look at things on remember
senator brownie has to send them to
raise their heads thank you so all hands
down at the moment go through these in
this order revised amendment presented
at the exact session which looks like
it's going to be just before or just
after if we do a revised amendment I'm
going to do it after we do the revenue
estimates on the first of June rather
than before because we're going to have
to get the revenue estimates done and I
on revised amendment on at that time on
the second one would be interim study
with performance audit requests that
over the next week the third one would
be without performance audit the fourth
one would be ITL so it goes back to the
first committee next time with
performance audit request and then
without this is pretty complicated but
is that acceptable so for those of us
who can raise our hands my zoom and
those who are doing it by star seven a
star nine sorry star nine please do
raise your hand if you would like to see
us go forward with a revised amendment
at the exact section that seems to be no
it's going up six anybody else that's
six six votes remember you can vote for
multiples
[Music]
the second is interim study of with a
performance audit request which we would
need to define so that we've got
everybody
that is nine votes looks like that's the
end of it the third is an interim study
it looks like it's stuck at 3:30 votes
the fourth is ITL with the performance
audit request yes
represent Tucker are you are you trying
to get our attention
yes I don't know how to raise my hand so
that's the one for me you want to be a
ticket discount yes I and maybe sometime
you could send me a little message to
find out I have an eye back other it
looks like we're stuck at 9 on that one
too and the fifth is ITL with a
performance on it you didn't want the
other one get a clean start
the one in the attendees would be Mary
Griffin that's right okay so so we've
so by one vote we've got intern study
with a performance audit request mm-hmm
coming out yeah we can think about those
as we go through and and we're both
groups are going to do caucuses before
the final event I would like to point
out that we won't have the results of
the performance audit back in time for
the interim study if it's possible to do
an interim
study at all at this point when we don't
know when we're going to be able to get
back together except in this format
which takes a lot of staff time but but
that that mm itor the performance
ordered are the ones that captured the
most votes so we should be prepared to
discuss those particularly in our
caucuses and take them to the executive
committee is as necessary you check it a
vote so does absent of Griffin want to
talk no then I say flashed for a minute
instead of lighting launched it's luck
thank you madam chair I guess my
question was could we do justice some
people may be holding off on what their
recommendation is based on yet five
different options and now we're down to
two can we just do another straw poll
with just the option of you know fix the
amendment and move it forward or IPO
with performance audit and see where
those votes land because obviously if
the sponsors are no it's going to be I
deal with performance audit they may not
bother worrying about a to fix the
amendment but if they want to if it
looks like we have votes to fix the bill
and move it forward fix the amendment
then they need to work on that so they
need to know to vote short of the ITL
and three votes short of the interim
study so if we're going to include that
we'd have to do a three-way vote I'm
just looking to make sure that if the
sponsors if they're expected to move
forward with the bill with the amendment
that they have time to get the amendment
we're gonna have to do three-way I'm
that's the only way to include the
revised amendment the first choice is
interim study with performance audit the
second choice is ITL where the
performance audit the third choice is 80
revised amendment to be discussed at the
executive session so on could everybody
raised there and who is in favor of
interim study with a performance audit I
don't know if I can but it's gonna be
any different now they are different
and the second one is ITL with a
and that one has nine votes and the
represent tiger had raised her hand did
you get that in the count
oh no so that's ten votes you mean I
believe so is that correct
um representative Tucker but correct
okay so that's ten bucks and a revised
amendment to be discussed and voted on
in the executive session please raise
the number 60 going up and down didn't
vote very I was trying to kick and I
punched the wrong the wrong buttons okay
so which one were you on the the I K the
idea was with the an audit is that what
I heard
yes yes okay and we have five the
revised amendment so the revised
amendment and the interim study with
performance audit tie this time and we
have 11 votes for which is a majority of
the committee for ITL with the
performance audit request on we can
consider other motions when we get to
the exact session but we aren't going to
have a whole lot of time I would like to
see someone from the group that is doing
the amendment work with us on what we
would ask the performance audit
committee to look at because it it's
quite important that we have the the
questions that are necessary to get at
how they are using the money and and how
they how that money shows up in the
accounting in and I'd like to invite
representatives Tringham who noticed
this problem to weigh in on that too
maybe we can try to send around to draft
I might I think I will try to get Chris
Shea to to help us with a basic draft of
a request I don't know if that's
appropriate
but I'll ask him on and then we could
work on refining it to make sure that it
does what it's what we supposed to do
which when you do a performance audit
the results come out it is a little
rather slow it's rather expensive too
but the results come out as a report to
the fiscal committee and the document is
released on the LBL
pages for anybody to read and the
department is requested to respond to
the fiscal committee - to the audit
department and then the fiscal committee
receives information on whether the
department once is willing to make the
changes that were requested of it by the
audit and it gets followed up on in
future years so it is a pretty powerful
it's so much slow tool reps Naomi may I
interrupt here please yes yes I could
help you guys with a letter and I
suggested a letter would be to the chair
of the committee with Senator Reagan
currently in CC to our office and what
your committee would want to do is as
you've stated identify what you
potentially see as some issues and what
you would like the audit to look at that
way when the committee does convene
they'd have an idea of you know why
their audits being requested in terms of
if the audit is done a report that is
presented to the fiscal committee but
our auditors would also be willing to
present that to the Ways and Means
Committee in future we were more than
happy to take our audits on the road to
the various committee they want that
that's that's very helpful thank you yes
that that has happened
not very often in ways that means but it
has happened in the past and reps have
Griffin do you want to talk
No she keeps on turning on and off I
grabbed the phone oh okay
can so I think that's enough at this
will be discussing these bills in in
[Music]
caucuses before we get to the exact
session and then again in the XX section
I think that we're going to have to put
the exact section following the revenue
estimates to make sure we get through my
students done and we then turn to HB
1627 FM I want to repeat that the reason
that I have been working hard on this
amendment with the sponsors is that well
there are two reasons one of them is
that I can represent major in on the
dedicated fund committee for quite a
while and our committee is charged under
roles with making sure that the
dedicated funds operate are set up
properly in legislation and are
reporting properly so this bill came to
us from environment and agriculture
there has had to be quite a lot of work
done in terms of the of the specifics of
when the money can be taken from other
funds when and if it gets back on and a
number of technical issues from the
policy committee that got incorporated
in as they they moved it entirely to
online
my second reason for working on this is
that I do not believe it's appropriate
that we have a department left in this
state that cannot work virtually as
necessary and to do online registration
of health certificates and and the other
one which I am forgetting which one it
is at this point is going to reduce the
staffing overload in the Department of
Agriculture quite a lot and make it
easier once it is set up for the
veterinarians to to work with this and
for people to get information on
presumably for people to get information
when there's been a rabies bite or
something of that sort so I had an
amendment that the last piece of which
unfortunately just came out last night
that is because I was told that if we do
not separate out the very clearly the
dates of permission and different
transfers into all of the component
parts that OLS would change the
amendment when it came to them and we
don't want to do that again part of the
problem has been that we took the
amendment two ls and they said there is
not sufficient specificity here they put
in the specificity and the department
was not happy with the specificity and
in fact it did not
three flex the timetable of where the
money is going back and forth I don't
know how many people have had a chance
to look at the amended version this
the yellow pieces are the parts that
were sent to everybody last week and the
I believe it was last week and the blue
are are really as far as I can tell
technical corrections to that to make
sure that every single change in who can
transfer money to whom and who can't is
separated out in the enacting language
and the repeal language at the proper
times so and then Chris a suggestion
I also returned to the original idea
sorry
idea I just managed to get myself out of
this Jennifer if you can go one page
down yes there to the original
suggestion that we had which is that I
broke off section 5 from section 4 in
the first section to allow the parts of
this complex amendment that would be
repealed after all the transfers stopped
to be removed cleanly from the language
of the law so that they would it would
not be be visible when it is no longer
necessary
for anything the rest of section one
ends with the database fund shelter long
no no they go back up a bit
or I can read it off myself put your
back up a bit there you go
the database funchal draw monies only
from grants appropriations and the fees
in RSA 437 88 it could just say the fees
in 43 437 8a but if they had sometimes
got extra money to further develop the
direct database for instance I wanted to
leave that option in then section 5 is
the part that gets repealed after five
years and it says that notwithstanding
section four of the funds shall be
initiated by transfers from agricultural
product and skill testing fund
established and the integrated pest
management fund and after the animal
records database is operational the
Commissioner may reimburse the
agricultural product and scale testing
fund and the integrated pest management
fund over a period of five years as laid
out in the sections that are towards the
end of the bill and one of the things I
learned during this process of amending
was that the Commissioner does not think
he will be able to totally reimburse
those funds on over a period of time we
didn't want to leave this completely
open-ended on those two funds contain
removed from their bylaw changes or over
a very long period of time removed by
reducing fees somewhat which fees would
have to bounce back after that period of
time because for three years
I think it's they were collecting fees
to pay for salaries that did not happen
because people were not hired in those
positions I am Not sure at this point
whether they were not hired because the
budget did not allow them to be hired at
that time or whether it was that the
previous commissioner did not like so
but the money is there it is not being
used for the purposes of the fund and
cannot be used unless they in they
expand what the fund is paying for
inside the department which they could
do themselves if they thought this was
necessary and so it is that money that
would be being siphoned off to the other
fund to create the database and on that
there would be an option at the end of
in the last three years of that period
to take the money back into those funds
and the Commissioner has told me that he
is not he does not believe that there
would be sufficient money to reimburse
all of it so that's the general
situation as we found it out as we did
as we tried to do this amendment I don't
know if
[Music]
representative I've lost the
participants now on the attendees if the
Commissioner or representative Bixby or
the Agriculture Committee wants to speak
on what I've just said or and correct me
or otherwise the Commissioner and
representative Bixby would you like me
to bring them both on on at the same
time can you do that or we can go one
after the other years is 385 five one
the Commissioner okay making nice him to
speak good morning
I think that chairman Omni has done a
very good job of summarizing the
situation and that very pleased with the
would the changes I think that does
exactly what what our intent is be glad
to answer any questions thank you that
was very brief do you want to say
anything
there you are yes so I was I have ones
very small concern which is on page two
it says section 4 in section 1 it says
the database are shallow only draw
monies from Grants appropriations and
fees in RSA 437 in the next section it
says notwithstanding the funds shall be
initiated by transfers from agricultural
products till and scale testing fund and
deemed and the integrated pest
management fund but it doesn't specify
that those the the possible transfers
from those funds in the first two years
of operability as mentioned in the later
sections would be allowed and I just
want to make sure that that
and I'm not sure if that if those would
be considered part of the initiation or
if that needs to be further amended in
order to take care of that
if he's still over here with us yes yes
go ahead on whether we are in lines
three to five the yellow part on we
ought to amend that to make reference
specific reference to I guess it would
be artists RSA 43054 a and and 4 34 35
24 a which are further towards at the
end which are the words that spend the
money in the first transfer the money in
the first two years to the database so
when what I would suggest is that when
this amendment is when you decide that
you want have a final version of this
you know LS will draft it but be clear
that you want what pieces you want
repealed when and then what pieces you
want remaining and and they would
coordinate that with the appeals and the
effective dates are those repeals so if
you needed certain language to still
exist through the fifth year and that
you see in the two-year part of it then
you would need to include it in both
places it's hard for me to respond
greatly to this because I can't see it
all at the moment yeah
right and not having Lori conversations
that you've had but I think that again
the committee would want to be quick
what they anticipate is going to happen
going forward when in five years from
now there's people trying to figure out
what did you intend to have happen yes
so so I think that that probably
wouldn't mean a references right there
too
to those this is just as complicated as
as the drunk driving legislation was and
this that that that yellow section
should include references to the parts
below that are for for a and and five at
the very end in about the second to last
page yeah that's done you're going
through them now well the eighties are
reference reference the first two years
when the transfers are going out from
those funds this is all after the fund
has been and been operationalized so for
two years after that funds can continue
to go out of the first two dedicate the
existing dedicated funds to support the
new dedicated fund for the database
the bees are after five years all
transfers and and section five in the
blue says that at the end of that period
the authority of the Department of
Agriculture to move
back and forth in anyway ends so that
eliminates the section up at the
beginning that we were looking at that
was is added on to the definition of the
we can just look at integrated
management pest management fund which is
on there now on which you had before
except that I duplicated on Roman four
which was in there before was was a
simple Roman four on referring to the
transfers both during the first two
years and during the last three years of
that the five years total I separated
them out into the part that would be
allowed to transfer the first two years
that's a and the part that would be
allowed to be transferred the second
three years on the last of the five
years that's B and then below that the
A's and the B's are appealed at two
years and five years respectively
so it's tell me if you're ready for them
from yes yes I think we're it's time to
go to the questions and I believe
representative Sandberg tried to put his
hand up before I started this so we'll
can you yes yes can you hear me now yes
I appreciate all the hard work you did
on this on page two the lines three
through seven you began you said
notwithstanding section for the funds
shall be initiated and then on line six
the Commissioner may reimbursed my
question is and I realize that there's
if I were in charge of a department
would I not come before and have drafted
or asked for more revenue from the
general fund I just don't like the idea
you've charged for people for
agricultural products scale testing fund
fees integrated pest management they
were going specifically toward that when
will this fund ever be reimbursed all
its money need to be reimbursed
commissioner Jasper wanted to yes yes if
I could when we began this process there
was a lot of uncertainty about just what
was going to be needed where I'd still
want to to allow for some flexibility I
expect most of the money it's not all
the money to actually come out of the
product and scale testing fund that
title is a little bit misleading but
that was the title that commissioner
Taylor chose decades ago so most of this
money the money comes from product
registration and that's all animal feed
really so it is appropriate and there is
a nexus because so much of that is pet
food so we believe that using that fund
really does fulfill the mission because
it goes to something that has to do with
with the animals so we knew we were not
going to get a general fund
appropriation and had to try to be
creative and how we could actually do
this because it would take a lot more
people to what I could actually
accomplish the goal of what the
legislature has tasked us with doing
which is to up all all of these the
licensing procedure for all these pet
vendors which is just
not humanly possible for us to do with
the staff we did get one more person on
board but we're still not doing what we
should be doing and so we did find the
Nexus
I think it's appropriate and ultimately
that is your judgment call may I follow
up with a question for the Commissioner
uh madam chair yes I have one too
commissioner Jasper uh if the word may
is turned to shell shell reimbursed does
the five-year period give you enough
time to maybe come up with an approach
to the General Assembly to fulfill the
amount of money that you will transfer
out I perhaps a little concerned by the
word shell but then I think it it also
says under yo under the another section
of the RSA which I think makes it clear
that I don't have to if the money's not
there so are we going to come up with
another way we don't know how much that
how much those fees are going to bring
in and again I mean this is really up to
the legislature we want to be reasonable
with the fee and at the same time you
know have some hope of reimbursing it my
idea originally was to leave that
open-ended the legislature to this point
is decided having that open-ended is not
the best idea so I thought all right
well maybe we'll do this in dribs and
drabs and it might take us a decade but
I understand the thought process there
so I think putting me in a little bit of
an unfair situation where my idea was
let's do it over whatever period of time
it takes but the legislature is saying
no you need to do within five years and
so now asking me to come up with another
way of accomplishing that really not
something I'm crazy about I'd rather
what commissioner Jasper well I got two
questions now one of them is do you this
money that we're talking about in these
dedicated funds is essentially one-time
money you are maintaining those two
programs at the extent that on you or
the US prior legislation considered
necessary on without that that money is
there something else that you can be
doing in in those areas and I'm more
concerned about the integrated pest
management fund which I don't think has
Nexus then is there something else you
can be doing with that money in the
future to absorb it or because
alternatively we ought to be either
lowering lowering the user fees which
would then require raising them again
once the money was spent thank you for
the question yeah that money was built
up essentially as one-time money under
the current mechanism that we're using
it
this is excess money however you know we
all know what state the revenue is and
so frankly one of my my thoughts which
would you know be through the budget
process would be to look at actually
using the excess revenues there in there
above and beyond even this to keep the
department operating without layoffs
because our we produce revenue generally
speaking when you when you look at what
we bring in and what were you
and then what we turn over to the
general fund we are about a break-even
if not a little bit net positive
operation here but if we are forced to
do layoffs we're likely to have a
negative effect on the general general
fund with no real positive results of
laying people off so I'd like to be able
to explore the possibility of keeping
our ability to generate revenues going
without during this crisis actually
having a drawdown on on the general fund
for our operations so that's sort of
where my thoughts are right now thank
you
we had representative streams seems to
be the only one with his hand up at the
moment yeah first of all madam chair
thank you for the great work on this
amendment if we're that seriously
concerned we're not going to be able to
replenish the fund at the end of five
years you know you said you wanted to be
kind of reasonable in terms of how much
to charge for this is $3 is not
reasonable
you know is $2 there really something
magical about the $2 number and I know
we talked about it a little bit before
but you know might we have a little
extra wiggle room if we've brought it up
to $3 or or somewhere between two and
three dollars you may well being in old
ways in meanors myself I'm very
cognizant that 125 percent rule that try
to operate within and and I think that
going beyond that $2 you know is sort of
a outside of that that realm even though
that you know is related to the fund
that's normal not normally the way we we
do that and I think there'll be a lot of
pushback we've already gotten to some
pushback but in the in the range of $2
I'm able to really say to the people are
going to be paying this fee you're
probably coming out about net neutral at
that point because you've got postage to
consider you've got to make copies
you've got to put it in envelopes there
are all these things that you have to do
versus if we do it electronically you're
going to save a lot on time and in
physical materials and postage but we
have gotten some pushback even at at the
level of going up to - my feeling was if
you know the legislature doesn't rightly
so want to give us a an open-end on the
fee we think that we're probably at a
dollar and a quarter maybe a dollar and
fifty cents and by the time we got to
that two dollar range it would be
appropriate for us to come back in a lot
and ask the legislature to allow us to
raise that fee if it gets the point of
being necessary again it's all you know
your call these were our our suggestions
on how to how to do this and garner
enough votes in the legislature and have
the support of the governor - to make
this a reality thank you for that the
other question I had for you madam chair
was why is wet why is the the sunset
provision on some of these provisions
set at five years for for the provisions
effect - well that's something that
perhaps we ought to discuss ten years
seemed much too long legislatively that
we would forget that this
on this sunset was in there at all and a
future Commissioner of Agriculture might
not happily go along continuing the
previous procedures without realizing
that it had sunsetted this has happened
quite frequently in in the legislature
partly because on things like that are
put into Chapter law and the chapter law
is only available to some people mostly
El Bao
and so you discover provisions such as
one that we just discovered that the the
Senate just discovered that the BRZ
program the economic redevelopment
revitalization zone program sunsets in
January and has a bill that that they
put in heartedly to fix that that they
added complications to that we haven't
not yet the program sunsets in January
and so we have to make a decision this
year and we're in combing and that kind
of thing has happened a number of times
over the years that something is in
Chapter law and we we do not remember it
on the Commissioner changes the
Commissioner doesn't remember it so it
just seemed like 10 years was too long
but I would welcome Commissioner
Jasper's thoughts on this or anyone else
who wants to madam chairman I I think
certainly that you know if we stay with
the five years we can revisit the
situation in five years and see what the
legislature to do at that point
but in unless there are any direct
questions for me right now unfortunately
I'm on a rather tight schedule and I
really need to drop off the call in the
next couple of minutes
[Music]
a minute on my the integrated pest
management fund is as a nexus it really
it really doesn't that's a you know but
the legislature is always free to do
what it wants as we know are too many
funds have been raided and we just
looked at this as where there was
available funding without totally
drawing down on to on the other fund
because obviously we have a guesstimate
as to what this program is going to cost
us but until we actually go out to bid
we're not going to know and so I didn't
want to leave us in a situation where we
were depleting one account and had too
much money there that you're correct
there's no nexus again that is the it's
within the purview of the legislature to
draw money from wherever it exists so if
we directed you to reimburse that one
first before the other one which does
have clear Nexus that would be very
reasonable that would be very reasonable
in my opinion yes okay just just so just
big picture by not having our votes with
us from the hearing to kind of think how
fast the Jenelle will be to the LOB
because without fees there's three
places where there's a two dollar fee
those days are all new correct and the
more on number two they will initially
those fees will go to this development
as well was the new computer system
if I may the fees are intended to go to
the annual maintenance cost of the
program that's the primary purpose again
we don't have set numbers but where
we've been told to expect that the
maintenance of this program is in the
range of about two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year on commissioner
Jasper I believe we only have two
thieves in this not three correct I
believe you're right but I've sort of
forgotten about this the details of this
bill it's been a while now so there are
if you look at it one way there are
three because there is a certificate
there's a health certificate waiver and
those could logically those are lumped
as one sort of thing but you could see
that as being two separate fees one for
one if you get the health certificate
waiver but you would not you would never
have someone who got both the health
certificate and the waiver so and then
separate from that there's the fee for
the for the rabies thank you me I'm
representing the Brahmi has to follow up
and would you like milk a screen share
would you like to keep that up um oh I
think can we put down the screen share
okay removes that rami product the
computer systems being developed the
first couple of years we start
collecting these fees if I may no that's
that's why we put the certification in
there that until such time as the
Commissioner certifies that the program
is operational no fees will be collected
it would be you know in my opinion
unfair to have people have to send in
potentially the paper documents and at
the same time pay a fee for the
electronic program which doesn't exist
so no fees until we're live ninety day
period in your timeline which suggests
that on during that period some people I
guess would be using this now
operational system and paying the fee
and other people would be using the
paper system I believe you're correct
because with anything it's going to take
some some live time to determine whether
the program is fully operational or not
we would probably pick a few communities
to to try it out these are very
complicated where we're trying to switch
over and weights and measures right now
this has been a process that's been
going on for a couple of years and very
very complicated so we anticipate
they'll be hopefully not as complicated
because we're creating a new program
versus trying to swap one over but
unless you have anything pressing for me
I do have to go and I apologize for that
that's for your time I think I represent
may be able to answer further questions
I I believe he will he's been very
okay
yes we're into lunch time now is there
anyone else who has a question I don't
okay so does anyone have any suggestions
for different amendments or we can
discuss actual emotions at our caucuses
and come to the exact way then if no one
has anything further this amendment I
believe that we can close the work
session on HP 1627 Committee for all the
hard work you've done thank you
represented basically and we can close
the work session yes there is nobody who
is raising their hand for any further
purpose so I am going to end this work
session we will be meeting again to do
revenue estimate oh sorry
have we lost some of us it's that part
of this the other part of this which is
fairly small but which is why Chris Shea
has been sitting through all of this and
helping us out occasionally any members
that we need to call back I'm not sure
that anyone has left just in this moment
we've lost one or two along the way
today yeah question
yes she does absent of Kamala said he'll
come back if he can and the amendment
for this previous film we are speaking
of didn't have the blue things the blue
additions on my copy
maybe I sent it late last night to
everybody
well I guess I was looking at Jennifer's
email maybe from yeah I that went out I
said you just after I think you said the
other one I've been working on things
still quite late at night I apologize so
we did want to briefly go through the on
with Chris Shea just what these new
forms we're going to use for revenue
estimates are next week for any
attendees that are listening this is
no estimates they are really going to be
a week from now so Chris can you talk to
us yes person follow me thank you for
that introduction so I'm the so there
was an email as part of the email that
you received yesterday you've got an
Excel worksheet and I can share my
screen to show it again to you but it's
the same thing basically the same sheet
that is that showing up for you guys
yes all right so it is just essentially
the same worksheet that you've seen if
you've been on the Ways and Means
Committee year after year what's
different is it we're really going to
have a agency look ranges and then House
Ways and Means Lo and hydrangeas as you
do your estimates and that change has
been made on each of the three tabs when
you get I'm gonna eat email you guys
this again Friday later in the day
potentially Saturday and depending on
when I get some of the agency responses
what you will get is hopefully a
populated worksheet on Friday for the
agency information so that when you're
sitting in the meeting on the 27 you'll
have an idea if you have this worksheet
up what the agencies providing for
revenue estimates or ideas for revenue
estimates additionally I will be sending
how
the agency written information so you'll
all get that as part of the email and
these documents will all be available on
the general court website the day of the
meeting as well but reps in Vaughn we
just wanted me to make sure that you
knew you're gonna get the worksheet it
was gonna be a live Excel worksheet that
you could select information in make
notes in it whatever you need to do for
each of the you know various funding
funds that you are gonna make estimates
on one I'm in the highway worksheet
right now and just so you understand if
you were to compare the official plan of
259 for in column D so that was what
your estimates were last time you did
the revenues for the budget if you go to
the revenue plan you're gonna see a
number of two 27.6 that's because the
administrative services backs out that
cost of collections and that's what I
show you in column GE I've also been
scheduling people to present to you on
the 27 so you're gonna start with Phil
Slaton Hampshire fiscal policy institute
he'll talk to you starting at 9:30 until
about 10:00 and then from 10:00 to about
noonish DRA will present on the various
revenues that they are responsible for
collecting and any information that they
can provide the committee that might be
helpful around one o'clock I believe the
Chamber of Commerce will come on to the
zoom meeting and there's two individuals
that are representing the Chamber of
Commerce that will talk about some of
the impacts they're the businesses they
represent or experiencing and then
starting at 1:30 you'll have the
Department of Insurance Department
Liquor Commission Lottery Commission and
Department of Safety all doing brief
presentations to you on their on their
revenues and then the remaining agencies
and I'll provide this list to you will
be available to answer questions but
they're not being asked to present
and part of the reason is because of the
the format that's being used and the
need to kind of streamline some of the
way to get information how we just asked
them to be available questions if you
receive the information Friday and
you're looking at over you know over the
long weekend and you start to think of
questions as it might relate to a
particular revenue source or or you have
another piece of information that you're
like oh I know agency X collects Y in
email and then I can reach out to the
agency and either try to get that
information prior to the 27th or at
least make the agency aware that they
may have a question coming to them so
they they're prepared to respond to you
again the effort is to get you as much
of the information you need as quickly
as we can so that you can come back on
June 1st and and make the official
estimates that you want that's really
all I had and that's the question for me
that's that's very well put thank you
yes so you hope we're going to get them
by Friday but it might be Saturday yes
so I've asked agencies to provide me all
their information by Friday the
challenge would be what time on Friday I
get it and when I get to update the the
worksheet and then get it out to you
right I will get it to you as quickly as
I can and again it'll be a live excel
sheet so that you can make notes you
know put numbers in it that you might
want to just see how they look and then
all the supporting documents that the
agency is providing I'll also forward to
you at the same time just so you have an
opportunity to look at that and will you
for those emails to us on individually
for it every single agency that reported
to you or are you going to combine them
into one large document hoping just to
send one large email thank you it'll be
easily found you know that you'll be
looking for a single email from from me
we'll have everything if it's if it's
too much information if that if the
documents are too large for whatever
reason maybe I need to
get into two or three emails but I'll
try to send them back to back to back so
you can find everything pretty easy and
number things like like email one out of
three yep yep and as I said is um you
know my if you have any questions or for
some reason you're not getting something
that you thought you should feel free to
reach out to me and we'll try to get it
resolved thank you and schanberg has a
question or comment Oh
Crips Chris yeah you take the general
fund spreadsheet and break it down into
an eight-and-a-half by eleven so I I
will set that put the settings at eight
and a half by eleven so if somebody
chooses to print it it'll not cause you
problems thank you
there was one technical issue that reps
um Schamberg identified I hadn't reset
the excel sheet to being a half by
eleven which if different it's probably
what you're printing yes I believe I did
a certain amount of making the columns
narrower and in order to achieve the
same thing it's much better if you do it
I'm representing with Brahmi had a
question so not every agency will give
you a high and a low
there are some that are doing that in
the material I've seen some are just
giving you a number you know they think
have a pretty good idea what they think
twenty is gonna end at and they're just
providing a number in those cases are in
your high and low I'll put the same
number obviously but there are some that
are saying that you know especially for
twenty one if they're giving you any
information for twenty one they're
saying it's too early to really know
where it's gonna land so they're giving
you a high and a low
okay thank you we understand a major yes
Chris to reach out to you we use your
legislative email only yes please okay
yes and he is available weekends as
necessary I wish there was a way that we
could avoid this kind of thing but he's
been very good about it any further
questions or discussion about how we're
gonna do the revenue estimates I think
all of us have been through this before
including Tim Lang who was on the
committee for two terms three before he
went off so we do have representative
Romney raising his hand again yeah I
just want to make sure we all understand
obviously usually go alone we talk about
the revenues I just want to make sure I
understand how these revenues obviously
flying high low I guess we're going to
do a high Lobo difficult doing it via
zoom for some reason so yeah I think
what we're going to be able to do is is
going to have to do is just raise hands
where we're going to be discussing them
which means that if you've got something
you want to discuss about each revenue
as we go along you raise your hand and
you talk and then we'll have to do a
little talking on at least some of them
before we try to to vote on numbers on
the first but the idea is that we'll get
substantial input during on the 27th and
then each party will hold a caucus and
discuss it further and then we'll get
back together on the first and and do
hopefully not
more conversation but there might be and
vote on each of these by raising our
hands unless there's some way to add the
other hand raising version say yes no
version on to this but there probably
isn't without a lot of trouble I'm so I
guess I'm still muted so so we're saying
your first yeah we we got to come in
with there could be 20 different
versions of this or conversion and
consensus or compromising those because
they could be upwards of they could be
upwards of 20 opinions major thank you
after the 27th I would plan to have a
Republican caucus stop talking about
revenues the caucus I assume you're
gonna do the same thing yes and then so
that we can go over it and we have
questions as a result of what we heard
on the 27th and discussion on the 28th
we can get those to Chris so we can get
the most up-to-date information and it
probably would have another caucus prior
to June 1st we don't have much time yeah
we don't have much time and you you are
busy I think all day on the 29th yes oh
god yes we've got another problem we
have a delegation of 90 representative
Tucker is raising her hand physically
so well we have to take a roll call vote
on this to take a vote buddy we're going
to pass under this format we are
required to take a roll
actually you're correct I said raise
hands on once we get to the to do first
we're going to be having to take a roll
call vote on every single tax or fee or
revenue whatever it is that's right I
assumed the case yeah just quickly to
point out to you if you go to I think
it's the lower right on the Mac and
the caucus I guess will come to terms
with hi-low versions appear on what Kris
is going to present the first discussion
that day will say well you know we can
compromise on a certain number is that
I'm trying to envision how it's going to
work that's the name I think we have to
do a certain amount of discussing of
these and not just listen to the agency
while we're going through the revenues
but do a certain amount of discussion if
to see if someone has particular
concerns from once one side on
particular revenues and if there's any
way that we can try to resolve them with
Chris Shea or otherwise before the first
we can in otherwise we're just going to
have to we've done this in
we've we've met in caucuses and then
we've gotten together and we are not we
are not necessarily voting in caucuses
when we when we get together again
people listen to each other and around
the room and usually in a straw vote
which I guess we can't do I'm gonna have
to ask about that and and people all of
a sudden say well I voted this way
differently for the rest of you because
because this and so we we all think
about it at that point and adjust
accordingly what each of us was going to
vote vote on but we haven't I guess
there been a few times when we have
voted a party-line when we got to
and other times people they've been
listening within their caucus the
caucuses give us a chance to spend more
time talking about things it's great the
starting point is I think it's going to
be this and sometimes usually it's only
five or six people who speak up but
their idea of what a number is gonna be
and then we come to consensus which is
fine it's just I just seems like it's
giving you a harder come to consensus
over zoom just thinking that's all it
has to be as much as possible a public
process we've never really done it it's
public process because nobody has ever
bothered to come in to the committee
room except occasionally a reporter who
wasn't involved with it but
I think that that we have to make a
start at it on the 27th we aren't just
there on the 27th to listen to what they
say we're there to ask questions and to
bring up extra factors that hadn't we
think hadn't been considered on and
hopefully we can take that back to the
two caucuses and talk about it further
and try to to resolve some parts of the
process and then bring it back on them
on June 1 and discuss it publicly and
get numbers out there represent South
Worth has a question represent of South
thank you just one idea perhaps after
the caucuses to make it easier what if
each caucus had a primary spokesperson
when you got to each section so other
people could speak but if there's one
person that you knew was always going to
kind of give a little presentation from
that caucus it would go a lot more
quickly you could still do some
consensus
you know votes but really I just think
sometimes when we're doing it too random
it just takes a little more time
bouncing around and so on just at that
it does but sometimes one person as an
idea as a rep said of or he did actually
for the the electric cars problem about
before yeah and it's important they be
able to speak also and then it not be
considered necessarily a caucus thing no
I agree with that I'm not trying to stop
that I'm just saying to always get us
started when you say business taxes
there'll be a person from each caucus
already to do a little something
then you can add anyone else you want
okay who wants to
yes okay that's a good idea if it's okay
with represent major advice to remember
of their committee just do your homework
before the 27th review you know ask good
questions that's what that's what we're
here for
get information thank you then and then
after we get through with all the
agencies the day after we can have our
separate caucuses discuss these issues
that we have and hopefully as a caucus
come to consensus Susan and I will be
communicating with each other the
caucuses because she could point out
something that we didn't consider and
maybe I could point out something that
they had come up with a bipartisan
agreement right and they at least know
places where we're gonna have to do more
discussion on the first but it's very
important do your homework before we sit
down on the 27th with the agencies
Thanks yeah most of us don't have a
Memorial Day parade we can dedicate it
to this
it was just canceled this morning we
have a small memorial event by a few
veterans only so okay go Marlo have
questions
ah okay rip Centers Tucker it isn't a
question - it's really a encouragement -
the sooner we can set the time or the
caucus the better right because I think
it's very important that each group be
able to meet isn't everyone there yes
knowing though
or whatever and I know your life is very
complex your clerk could give you the
hand or yes okay I just like to throw
out that they I'm not sure whether all
of our caucus members could get together
on Friday
that's when Rockingham is working all
day long or whether you'd rather that we
did it on Thursday or Saturday or is
represented stream still this I can't
see part of the screen because of the
and raising stuff yes there you are yes
posters as a meeting is that what you're
saying yeah I don't know what other
people are in for that idea or not but
think about it in and someone will be
contacting you fine
we're supposed to be delivering masks
from 10:00 to 2:00 on Saturday okay that
sounds like a good thing to do represent
go Marla oh I was just gonna ask if
Christmas going to do a share of that
excel sheet and fill in the blanks like
Willis did for us before and that would
be very helpful so the first one you
guys are meeting I can certainly do that
yep okay Reverend Southworth raises him
sounds please yes I just wanted to make
sure is there really a conflict on
Friday
I thought the Rockingham people didn't
say it was a conflict I'm trying to
remember yeah I thought so too
Oh
well if it isn't for must for our side
perhaps in those we was that person yeah
yes
I'm just saying that I have to have a
one o'clock conference call with but
theythey Naval Observatory so to get off
right now yeah yeah I think we're we're
pretty much finished
I'm the Democratic side morning or
afternoon just start
I remember San Mames all right fine
anytime okay represent a major edges
handle it yeah we we will be busy in
Rockingham all Friday we may have to
have another day too
we have to it's on budget County so I'm
taking votes by departments it's gonna
take forever
what plan on having a caucus on Thursday
okay so that that gives us to the two
caucus states on the 28th on the
Democratic side people can spend some
time looking at everything that we've
got and I'm writing down so I won't
forget it again I forgot a caucus
yesterday on for the caucus for the 29th
10:00 a.m. good thank you all
I'm sorry Kerry kisses hand oh it's Otis
Janet Jenny first Jenny Stone has her
hand up like 28 blue I can't be at the
caucus on the 29th in the morning I can
be there in the afternoon
okay so we'll have to start at 1:00 p.m.
okay okay so Jenny I had except on those
two bills on the 28th but we're gonna do
it on the first or another it's on the
first yeah I'm not sure I think that
might have been under consideration at
one point or another I think so too
okay yeah it's been very confusing I do
apologize and we've lost the other
person who had their hand up so I think
that we can leave each other for the
moment and hopefully represent a bowler
he can get a bite to eat before he has